[Musik]
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren zu
hause den bildschirmen
mein name ist hauptmann krieger posch
voran und ich darf sie seitens der
gerade recht herzlich in der maria
theresien kaserne begrüßen zum tradition
star gerade mit angelobung und übergabe
des unteroffiziers evtl
kommentiert wird der festakt von
hauptmann michael meier vom kommando der
garde
es werden heute insgesamt 230 guten der
zweiten garde komponiert das einrücken
termins mai 2021 angelobt die übergabe
des unteroffiziers stellt einen
höhepunkt des heutigen tages dar und
unterstreicht die bedeutung des
unteroffiziers kurs im bereich der garde
im anschluss schalten wir in die
präsidentschaftskanzlei zu
bundespräsident dr
alexander van der bellen der in der
letzten woche den unteroffizier selber
dem gerade genannten überreicht hat
[Musik]
geehrte ehren und festgäste sehr
geehrter herr oberstleutnant thomas
götzberger geschätzte soldatinnen nur
soldaten der gerade aufgrund der
schwierigen gesundheitssituation liegt
ein ausgesprochen anspruchsvolles jahr
hinter uns
ich möchte daher die feierlichkeiten
anlässlich des traditions- tages der
gerade nutzen und einfach danke schön
sagen auch wenn die
repräsentationsaufgaben wegen cupid 19
nicht im gewohnten umfang stattfinden
konnten haben sie in anderen bereichen
in erheblichem ausmaß zur bewältigung
der aktuellen herausforderungen der
korona pandemie beigetragen die
ausbildung von circa 1600
grundwehrdienern für repräsentations und
einsatzaufgaben unter den aktuell
schwersten bedingungen die formierung
den wie in teil mobil gemachten
milizsoldaten mehrere assistenzeinsätze
für die gesundheitsbehörden und die
abstellungen für den assistenzeinsatz
migration möchte hier nur exemplarisch
erwähnen wo die breit angelegte
ausbildung der soldatinnen und soldaten
und die engen verbindungen des
bundesheers zu zivilen institutionen
machen es möglich dass herausforderungen
abseits des unmittelbar militärischen
spektrums professionell und erfolgreich
bewältigt werden können
das österreichische bundesheer stützt
sich dazu auf ein starkes und
kompetentes und offizierskorps bestens
ausgebildet und didaktisch geschult
vereinen die unteroffiziere die aufgaben
des kommandanten ausbilders unterziehen
person und fungieren als bindeglied
zwischen der militärischen führung und
den soldatinnen unserer garten der
mannschaftsdienstgrade das
bundesministerium für landesverteidigung
hat ein unteroffizier gerade nach
historischem vorbild ermöglicht im
rahmen von ehren bestellungen einen
infanterie leben zu führen
ich möchte daher die gelegenheit nutzen
und dem gerade kommandanten
stellvertretend für die und offizieller
der gerade als dank für ihren einsatz
symbolisch einen säbel überreichen
nicht zuletzt die krone krise führt uns
vor augen wie wichtig eine fachlich
fundierte und auf soziale kompetenz
abzielende ausbildung unserer
führungskräfte ist
insgesamt möchte ich allen soldatinnen
und soldaten der garde und des
bundesheers für ihren engagierten
einsatz danken und ihnen weiterhin viel
erfolg für die erfüllung ihrer aufgaben
wünschen
schade dass ich heute nicht persönlich
bei ihnen sein kann und mit ihnen diesen
tradition star zu begehen
aber ich freue mich stellvertretend für
sie alle herrn oberstleutnant
petersberger jetzt hier in der
präsidentschaftskanzlei willkommen zu
heißen
[Musik]
gerade gut
jetzt hier herzlich willkommen zurück in
der maria theresien kaserne in kürze
erfolgt das ankündigung signal und im
anschluss meldet der gesamt kommen die
rentabilität den höchst anwesenden
danach wird die bundeshymne abgespielt
nach dem abschreiten der front und der
flanke rat begrüßt der gerade command
die anwesenden soldaten und auch sie zu
hause ein choral leitet über zu den
worten der geistlichkeit und der säbel
ein weiteres musikstück leitet über zur
übergabe des und office tables anders
und offizierskorps
danach spricht der militärkommandant von
wien seine worte und ein musikstück
leitet über zur ansprache des civil
zivilen höchst anwesenden darauf folgt
eine fanfare und wir kommen zur
angelobung mit dem zeugnis
nach dieser angelobung erfolgt das
musikstück oder in österreich es erfolgt
das anbieten um weitere befehle und das
abrücken der ehrenformation beendet den
traditionsklub der garde mit angelobung
und feierliche übergabe des un official
says
ich wünsche ihnen eine schöne
veranstaltung und alles gute nach hause
[Musik]
das gatter ehrenkompanie ehrenkompanie
presse hier das ganze recht schaut ja
general hauptmann mehr meldet eine
ehrenkompanie abordnungen der garde
sowie 215 an zu geloben rekruten zum
tradition stuck und zur feierlichen
angelobung angetreten
anke beginnen mit dem festakt beginnen
[Musik]
ja genau hauptmann mehr mächtig ab
das ganze ehrenkompanie
[Musik]
das kannte ehrenkompanie ehrenkompanie a
m
gut das ganze hat
[Musik]
ich schätze ich kann man ander gerade
zur angelobung des einigungstermin 2021
in verbindung mit unserem traditions-
tag darf ich die ehrengäste mit begrüßen
nämlich zu beginn den mit der schöpfung
lesenden jahren general magister robert
rieger als ranghöchster offizier des
österreichischen bundesheers regionalen
herzlich willkommen begrüßte den
militärkommandanten von wien herr
premierminister grundlage nachhaltiger
wir ebenfalls herzlich willkommen
in vertretung des bürgermeisters von
wien das ich begrüßen herr magister
marcus schober auch die herzlich
willkommen herr magister schön dass du
wieder da bist immer ein herzliches
willkommen nicht richtig haben die
bezirksvorsteherin des 13
wiener gemeindebezirks frau magister
silke kobalt grüß gott und auch ein grüß
gott daran die hohe geistlichkeit
unseren militärpfarrer herrn ärzte kann
dr altrip sie auch erst der kampf ist
und ich begrüße meinem jüngsten soldaten
bei einer zweiten jahr die compagnie zu
ihrer angelobung die umstellung von der
zerbrechlichen zivilen welt in das
robustere militärische organisierte
umfeld haben sie ja offensichtlich recht
gut vollzogen
die von mir angesprochene zerbrechliche
zivile welt beziehungsweise umfeld kann
ich mit der aussage oder mit den daten
belegen dass es im letzten jahr doch
dieses jahr noch zu vielen spontan
einsetzen des österreichischen
bundesheeres auch der garde gekommen ist
wo wir nicht wie immer prolongiert als
da als strategische reserve einzusetzen
sind sondern als first responder
eingesetzt wurden ich erinnere an die
rasche verfügbarkeit unserer soldaten
bei der unterstützung der post ag
letztes jahr kurz vor vor dem osterhasen
ich erinnere an die rasch verfügbaren
kräfte auch der garde in zur betreibung
der callcenter sie per tages und und
immer noch beim außenministerium und
andere drucken die sogar in pflegeheimen
sofort verfügbar waren um dort
besatzungen original besetzen zu können
also das österreichische bundesheer ist
mittlerweile leider möchte man sagen
schon first responder das betrifft auch
die kameraden der zweiten jahreshälfte
woche noch bei ihnen in horn war und
ihnen auch gesagt habe ihre zukunft die
es noch unklar
die zukunft ist etwas entrückt
mittlerweile und auch für sie ist ein
einsatz ab juli nun absehbar egal in
welcher funktion
die junge kameraden der zweiten garde
kampagne ihren dienst versehen werden
wir waren sie sich wie hier bei der
jahre an sie vermittelt disziplin um in
ihrer dienstzeit schwere unfälle
vielleicht sogar ansteckung durch die
pandemie zu vermeiden wie waren sie sich
die disziplin bleiben sie diszipliniert
ich habe bisher einen sehr guten
eindruck von ihnen gewonnenen soul in
horn also heute hier bei ihrem ersten
quasi öffentlichen auftritt auf das
können sie stolz sein weil ich bin auch
stolz auf sich auf die auftreten und auf
ihre leistungsbereitschaft bisher und
ich wünsche ihnen also kommen für die
restlichen fünf monate egal in welcher
funktion ist sie dann ihren dienst
versehen werden alles gute und viel
soldaten
[Musik]
geschätzter herr general militär
kommandant oberstleutnant werte
vertreterin werte vertreter des
öffentlichen lebens aber insbesondere
sie lieber jüngste soldaten aus der
zweiten garde kompanie wir konnten uns
letzte woche ja schon in horn bei der
ausbildung kennen lernen
geschätzte abordnungen aus den einzelnen
garde kompanien liebe kameraden und
freunde
insbesondere die jüngsten soldaten
werden heute geloben österreich mit
allen kräften und auch dem volk zu
dienen
im römerbrief 15 kapitel finde ich dazu
ein wort nimmt einander an heißt es dort
nimmt einander an dass soldaten dienst
erlaubt liebe kameraden keine
gleichgültigkeit und wie sie schon in
den ersten wochen gemerkt haben ist das
meistens so dass keine alleingänge
möglich sind denn die herausforderungen
sind groß vor denen wir stehen das leben
in einem sympathischen verband wie der
garde ist auf gegenseitige hilfe und
auch verlässlichkeit auf ein miteinander
aufgebaut das werden sie wahrscheinlich
auch schon ganz rasch gemerkt haben und
dazu kommen dann noch die seelischen und
auch die körperlichen belastungen so
manche entbehrung hinzu die darin
gipfeln können dass der soldat auch in
situationen gerät in denen er seine
gesundheit oder sogar auch sein leben
aufs spiel setzen muss geschätzte
festgemeinde in österreichischen
bundesheer zu dienen heißt tradition zu
haben mit einem wertebezug dabei ist zu
nennen freiheit demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit dazu gehören auch
die ausübung der religionsfreiheit
der glaube an gott ist deshalb auch ein
wesentlicher bestandteil begann die
tradition wie es auch am insignium mit
der mutter gottes zu sehen ist das immer
und stets bei allen ausrückungen so
sichtbar mitgetragen wird
und wir tun gut auch in dieser stunde
des traditions- tages zu unterscheiden
viele überlieferte formen sitten und
gepflogenheiten sind nicht tradition
sondern sind brauchtum
also militärische gewohnheiten und auch
förmlichkeiten das brauchtum ist gerade
im bereich der gerade wichtig für die
truppe für unsere soldatische
gemeinschaft es fördert zusammenhalt es
fördert kameradschaft
es stärkt das wir-gefühl und es gibt
handlungssicherheit auch im oft
schwierigen militärischen alltag bei den
entscheidungen und gerade in einer welt
die kameraden des permanenten wandels
und auch der wachsenden unsicherheiten
gibt braucht um den soldaten
orientierung und halt und so auch der
militärische braucht der verleihung und
übergabe des unteroffiziers ebel säbel
zu verleihen geht eigentlich in die
geschichte zurück auf die schwert leite
der ritter im mittelalter
da der damals die ritter vom könig ihre
waffen empfangen hatten
und nach den texten die zu diesen
segnungen verlesen wurden sollen die
waffen vor allem eines tun die
gerechtigkeit schützen es geht es um die
gerechtigkeit in dieser form der segnung
des schwertes damals wurde gott vor
allem um den schutz des ritters gebeten
die zweckbestimmung des schwertes selbst
wird in dem gebet und in den texten in
einem anrede eingewoben förmlich an den
träger umgestaltet die man rede setzte
also der zukünftigen verwendung des
schwertes sehr enge grenzen
nun mit den reformen mit der neuen zeit
mit der mit den änderungen auch in der
gesellschaft im laufe der geschichte im
wandel der geschichte gehört der waffen
sehen gott sei dank auch der
vergangenheit an
so ist das heutige segensgebet dass sich
nun über die vorbereiteten segel säbel
sprechen werde
ein segensgebet im blick auf diejenigen
unteroffiziere die den säbel tragen
werden damit sie freiheit demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit schützen und dabei
niemanden ungerecht verbunden
bitte denken sie daran der säbel hat als
waffe ausgedient wenn wir den säbel
segnen dann segnen wir also keine waffen
wir bieten vielmehr dass du kennt hafte
ideal für unsere geschätzten kameraden
die unter offizieren
die diese säbel danach tragen werden ich
darf besonders inneren werte kameraden
die sie heute angelobt werden einladen
einzutauchen in dieser militärische
tradition und das brauchtum auch der
garde lernen sie in den kommenden wochen
und monaten auch daraus zu leben leben
sie es nehmen sie sich auch etwas mit
für weiteres leben leben sie die
kameradschaft in diesem sinne segne sie
gott
unsere hilfe ist im namen des herrn der
himmel und erde erschaffen hat lasset
uns beten wir bitten dich oh herr segne
diese säbel und unsere jungen unter
offizieren
diese tragen werden und bewahre sie in
der ausübung ihres dienstes unversehrt
hilft ihnen recht volk heimat und glaube
zu schützen und niemanden ungerecht zu
verwunden soweit es die menschliche
gebrechlichkeit zulässt durch christus
unseren herrn
amen
letztlich kann man an der garde der
traditions- tag dieses jahr ist wieder
mal einer und der ausschluss der
öffentlichkeit leider ich hoffe das wird
sich nächstes jahr dann wieder zum guten
wenden aber es soll in erinnerung
bleiben dass wir zumindest diesen auch
und der öffentlichkeit ausgeschlossen
traditionswerk eine besonderheit
erhalten haben nämlich den hebel für das
und offizierskorps gerade welche man ab
sofort im rahmen der information die
ähren zugs genannten dieses und
offiziers aber auch verwenden
beziehungsweise tragen werden
somit darf ich zu mir bitten den
protokoll und office ihrer jahre um ihn
symbolisch den säbel für die
unteroffiziere bereichen
das leben eines jeden zur weiteren
verwendung und deren zug skandals im
rahmen der fall ist
hiermit übernehme ich denn doch selber
[Musik]
der general sehr geehrte abgeordnete
sehr geehrte frau bezirksvorsteherin
geistlichkeit eigentlich vegetarier
insbesondere rekruten hatten gerade
komponiert wie bereits angesprochen
haben wir ein festakt mit zwei adressen
es geht zum einen um die angelobung der
rekruten dass ein drittes terminal und
gleichzeitig feiern wir den
traditionszug der garde und gedenken
dabei der umbenennung des damaligen
herres wachbataillons am 15 mai 1957 in
gerade batterien
dazu ist die garde so weit ist die
laufenden einsätze überhaupt ermöglichen
so weit als möglich eben geschossen
angetreten und das ist wie immer ein
sehr beeindruckender anblick erklärte
der general
ich darf dir auch in diesem rahmen im
namen von sein zu der bemerkenswerten
wald zum chairman of duty und juni und
military komitee gratulieren und ich
darf die besonders dafür danken dass du
diesen festakt in sehr kleinem kreis
durch seine anwesenheit auszeichnung ist
vielen dank der mehrfache hat bereits
einiges über gewohnheiten und brauchtum
angesprochen tradition meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren bedeutet
eigentlich dass wir das in der gegenwart
weitergeben was ich in der vergangenheit
schon getan hat
bewährt hat und mit dem man aller
voraussicht nach auch in der zukunft
erfolgreich sein wird seit dem 15 157
und der damaligen umbenennung des
materials inc jahre batterien hat sich
ja wirklich sehr verwickelt hat
geblieben sind aber klassische werte im
bundesheer klassische werte die wir auch
bei unseren einsätzen heute und auch in
der zukunft im inland und dem ausland
brauchen werden ob es um den schutz von
räumen und objekten geht es um
assistenzleistungen und hilfeleistungen
geht oder ob das schwierige einsätze im
ausland im kosovo
bus und herzegowina in mario dem libanon
sind
wir brauchen zum beispiel werte wie
disziplin und kameradschaft wie gehorsam
und wachsamkeit
sie sind auch heute für die erfüllung
unserer aufgaben von entscheidender
bedeutung
tradition erfordert natürlich auch dass
man altes bekanntes nicht kritiklos
einfach übernimmt sondern normen und
werte sind natürlich auch heute auf eine
entsprechende gültigkeit zu überprüfen
und das heißt natürlich auch dass man
neuem gegenüber aufgeschlossen sein muss
sowie dass die karte auch immer macht
altes bewährtes schätzt und neues
annimmt verantwortung für die
gemeinschaft übernimmt wobei das
vorgesetzter für seine untergebenen
eintritt wo man die menschenwürde
geachtet und bei allen einsätzen die
teilweise vom columbus altersberger
bereits angesprochen worden sind leistet
die garde einen entscheidenden beitrag
zur auftragserfüllung alle einsatz über
die letzten fast 16 monate ist
anzusprechen die an einer im rahmen der
pandemie geleistet wurden das würde den
rahmen dieses festaktes urspringen aber
die garde ist immer noch dabei bei der
überwachung von gewährten objekten in
wien bei der grenzüberwachung
niederösterreich und im burgenland und
bei der unterstützungsleistung für das
außenministerium
ich darf alle hinter gerade aufrichtig
danken die zur erfüllung dieser einsätze
und das waren wirklich viele und lange
dauernde einsätze so wichtige leistungen
gezeigt haben und zur auftragserfüllung
beigetragen haben
rekruten der zweiten garde komponiert
sie ist in unseren jüngsten mitarbeiter
sie gehören dem bundesheer und diesem
vorzeige verband erst seit wenigen
wochen an
ich habe auch ihre ausbildung bereits
senioren gesehen
sie haben in horn und in wien ihre
ersten ausbildungsschritte absolviert
und haben sich hier bewährt und ich
danke ihnen dass sie sich für den teams
vom bundesheer entschlossen haben die
meisten verlieren werden auch in zukunft
der karte angehören
das ist der einzige verband der der
repräsentation dient und gleichzeitig
keine in vertriebs des scheins verwandt
ist
das ist eben ein doppelt auftrag und so
wie es dem leitspruch der garde auch
heißt der wehrpflicht eine wirklich
fordernd aber auch sehr schöne aufgabe
andere von ihnen werden also im
täglichen dienstbetrieb eingesetzt
werden um zum beispiel als wachsoldaten
oder als kraftfahrer verändert werden
und hier ihren beitrag für die
sicherheit österreichs leisten
gemeinsam mit ihnen den grundwehrdienern
bereiten wir uns im bundesheer insgesamt
auf die militärische landesverteidigung
vor das ist und bleibt die hauptaufgabe
des bundesheeres
darauf sind unsere fähigkeiten
ausgerichtet
und dazu können sie als grundwehrdiener
gemeinsam mit berufssoldaten
milizsoldaten unseren zivilbediensteten
zur auftragserfüllung beitragen und es
das glaube ich wirklich wird auch sehr
sehr rasch von ihnen eingefordert werden
dass das was im treuegelöbnis jetzt
versprechen nämlich die bevölkerung zu
schützen
auch tatsächlich zu leisten haben werden
wo sie in zukunft auch tätig sind
ob als gardesoldaten als kraftfahrer
oder als soldat oder welcher funktion
auch immer
setzen sie sich mit all ihren
persönlichen fähigkeiten fertigkeiten
und kenntnissen ein
dann werden sie persönlich auch sehr
sehr viel aus ihrem grund verdienst und
ihrer zeit beim bundesheer mitnehmen
ich gratuliere abschließend noch einmal
ein soldaten da gar nicht aus dem
heutigen traditions- tag und bedanke
mich als militärkommandant von wien
wünsche ich unseren neuen rekruten alles
erdenklich gute für die kommenden
tätigkeiten und aufgaben viel erfolg
zum wohl der bevölkerung und symbol
unserer heimat der republik österreich
[Musik]
sehr geehrter herr general särge der
militärkommandant geschätzte frau
bezirksvorsteherin sehr geehrte
kameraden und kameradinnen aber vor
allem sie werte rekruten in vertretung
von bürgermeister michael ludwig darf
ich mich nur bedanken dass es sich beim
dienst beim österreichischen bundesheer
entschieden haben ihr mandant hat
bereits gesagt dass sich die
sicherheitssituation rund um österreich
maßgeblich verändert hat dass es auch
zerbrechlicher geworden ist mit der
pandemie haben wir auch gesehen dass es
auch im eigenen land zerbrechlich werden
kann
und das sind dinge auf die wir uns
vorbereiten müssen ist eine
grundausbildung in horn absolviert kann
mir vorstellen wenn das wetter in wien
nicht besonders war dann möchte ich mir
nicht vorstellen will sehen wo an war
deswegen möchte mich auch dafür die
disziplin bedanken was mir auch gesagt
wurde die sich gehabt dann bei ihnen und
vor allem auch bei ihren vorgesetzten
ich glaube sie werden vorbereitet auf
wichtige dinge die man im bundeswehr
braucht es steht auch hier
wir schützen österreich und das ist
etwas was das bundesheer rund um die uhr
macht ganz wichtig ist es auch dass wir
das politische fundament dafür legen
dass sicherheit garantiert werden kann
und weil ich die bezirksvorsteherin
angesprochen habe ich darf mit ihr schon
einige male über sicherheit sprechen
auch wenn man nicht derselben fraktion
angehört so ist es glaube ich ganz
wichtig dass sicherheit für uns das
fundament der demokratie ist dass
sicherheit etwas elementares für die
republik ist weil wir heute auch eine
fahne gehisst haben das ist natürlich
bei jeder militärischen feier im
mittelpunkt das hissen der fahne sie
werden mitbekommen haben dass es auch
hier zu innenpolitischen diskussionen
gegeben hat und ich bin der festen
überzeugung dass das bundesheer mit ein
grund dafür ist dass überhaupt
international eine solche beachtung
haben
seit 1960 wird das bundesheer
internationale friedenseinsätze zur uno
soldaten und soldatinnen sind seit
jahrzehnten im friedenseinsatz und
darauf können wir stolz sein dass wir
durch diese leistung und sechs geworden
sind und dass wir natürlich eine
besondere beachtung haben alle anderen
dinge werden sich auf einer anderen
ebene klären
weil der herr general heute da ist darf
ich auch in vertretung der stadt wien
mich für die einsätze in der
unmittelbaren vergangenheit betracht
ich möchte ich in das jahr 2015
zurückgehen ich habe das auch schon
einige male erwähnt dass wir die
flüchtlingskrise 2015 nicht ohne dem
militärkommando wien so gut überstanden
hätten
über eine million mahlzeiten wurden
zubereitet für menschen auf der flucht
und wir haben 2020 gesehen dass das
österreichische bundesheer war das
sofort im einsatz war und ich möchte
mich auch hier bedanken dass wir immer
informiert worden dass wir immer
dementsprechend präsentiert bekommen
haben motors bundeswehr im einsatz ist
und hier auch der persönliche tanken den
militärkommandanten der uns damals durch
die test straßen geführt hat uns gezeigt
hat wie dieser ansatz funktioniert
ich habe den assistenzeinsatz
angesprochen und damit der kommandant
hat auch schon gesagt sie werde rekruten
sind die jüngsten mitarbeiter des
bundesheers ich darf es überzeugt ein
miliz hat sie welche reicht dazu auch
bewegen nachzudenken im bundesheer
beruflich zu bleiben oder als mediziner
zu bleiben ich kann ihnen aus eigener
erfahrung sagen das ist etwas ganz
spannendes und es gibt wahrscheinlich
keinen arbeitgeber der interessanter ist
und der vielfältiger ist also ich würde
mich freuen wenn sie da auch
dementsprechend sich das anschauen
ministerium hat gesagt dass sie sind die
jüngsten mitarbeiter und sie werden dann
auch die zukunft des bundesheers 1
ich glaube daran dass wir gemeinsam
dafür kämpfen dass das bundesheer auch
finanziell gut ausgestattet ist dass wir
in die zukunft blicken müssen dass wir
auf weitere sage ich jetzt mal vorfälle
vorbereitet sind und da hoffe ich dass
alle zusammenarbeiten
es lebe das österreichische bundesheer
es lebe die republik österreich
[Musik]
das ganze hab ihn sind ja gerade
vortreten
eingeteilt der rekruten vortreten
na gut dann so oder kloten spricht mir
nach ich gelobe mein vaterland die
republik österreich
und sein volk zu schützen und mit der
waffe zu verteidigen
ich gelobe den gesetzen und den
gesetzmäßigen behörden treue und
gehorsam zu leisten
alle befehle meiner vorgesetzten
pünktlich und genau zu befolgen und mit
allen meinen kräften der republik
österreich und dem österreichischen volk
zu dienen
nicht gut an
von nja eingeteilte recruitern eintreten
insignien der garde antreten
[Musik]
das ganze gerade gut das ganze hat
ehrenkompanie show and company presse
hier das ganze
general hat nunmehr meldet die
beendigung des traditions- tages und der
feierlichen angelobung und bittet um
weitere befehle abrücken
das ganze affäre company ehrenkompanie
kann man übernehmen abrücken
nein
[Musik]